[Wyatt Russell] I purposely obviously don't
look up stuff on the internet - I think it's
poison for the most part
[John Walker] I am Captain America.
[Wyatt Russell] Oh, God. Well, I know- so you're
gonna have to forgive me because I don't know
a ton about Marvel Cinematic Universe's
history. I know that Hydra is like- bad.
Hail Hydra! *groans*
So I think he'd be looking for the first
person to I guess take down if someone if
he heard Hail Hydra I think he'd be on
his feet trying to take somebody down
Hail Hydra! x4
I- I was nervous that they got the wrong person
because I didn't know who they wanted me to be
and then they said, "Oh, no, it's this
guy and this is sort of his story arc" and
they thought that I was you know right for the
role and then I could do a good job and then I
thought about it for a little bit and when I first
turned it, I was like, "Oh-oh, I got it? Oh, no."
[John Walker] Here's the thing: I'm
not Tony Stark, I'm not Dr. Banner,
okay. I don't have the flashiest
gadgets, I don't have super strength-
[Wyatt Russell] It's very physical,
it requires you know- you're there for
12/10 hours a day trying to- (there's) a
lot of physicalities (involved and) that you know
you're tired and you're sore and you're trying.
Well, I'm not 25 anymore it takes a little bit
longer to recover and you know you got to be
in a little bit better shape, I think
than I thought originally, to sustain.
And then mentally it's like, "Yeah you kind of got
to get over the fact that like you're wearing this
helmet", that it's like how do I act
with the stupid thing on, you know,
like how do I act in the suit?
It's a totally crazy thing
to wear when you're wearing.
It looks kind of-
When you're doing it you're like does
this look totally stupid or is it cool?
I can't tell because you're
just you know you're acting
with a big screen behind (and) you have
no idea what's there so you kind of have
to remind yourself like, "Okay, I'm not- forget
about the suit, you know just forget about it."
That was probably you know-
Mentally, you just have to
forget about what you're wearing.
I stay in my house a lot, no one's
recognized ever recognizes me because
I probably have this huge beard and a mask on
half the time so I don't know it feels fine.
I purposely, obviously, don't look up
stuff on the internet (because) I
think it's poison for the most part.
And it doesn't help me like be
better at my job or feel better-
Certainly doesn't help anybody
feel better about themselves,
so I don't read anything, I don't
look up anything, I just live my life
and so someone else said something but no one's-
I don't know, I guess no one recognized me.
It's great! I like to keep it that way.
I feel like since I saw this one (meme) I
don't need to see anymore because this one
is definitely the winner, with the "Up" guy?
Like the old man from "Up".
That's the best one, that to me is like
whoever did that I wish that they would like-
I don't know how you can find who
like the first person who did it was,
but they should be given an award by the internet.
I don't think I was ever in disbelief.
I don't know if I'm the guy that you really want
because I haven't done a lot of MCU-type stuff.
It wasn't what I did but they
liked that about what it was so-
It wasn't disbelief, it was sort of
just not knowing if I could do it myself
but now I'm happy with what it was.
If you don't think that
you can be good in the role
or you don't like it then just don't do
it you know it doesn't matter how big or
small the role is you just do things
that you think you can be good at.
[Bucky] I know what we have to do.
[John Walker] A word of advice then.
Stay the hell out of my way.